die feuerwehr von bee county im
us-bundesstaat georgia hat kürzlich
dieses video einer dramatischen rettung
eines kindes auf ihrer social media
website veröffentlicht die aufnahmen
entstanden anfang januar und wurden nach
angaben der rettungskräfte per
helmkamera gefilmt mehrere eltern
zeigten großes vertrauen in die
feuerwehrleute und ließen nach aussage
eines retters ihre babys wie bälle in
die arme der feuerwehrleute fallen
bei dem brand in dem gebäude sind
örtlichen medien zufolge über zehn
personen verletzt worden dabei habe es
sich jedoch vor allem um
rauchvergiftungen gehandelt